foreign
[Music]
I'm a Solutions engineer at posit and
I'm really thrilled to be up here today
to talk about quarto because in many
ways the vision of quarto that
reproducible research is a core part of
high quality scientific Communications
was a key driver in actually nudging me
along my career Journey that ultimately
has brought me to posit
almost 10 years ago as a graduate
student our markdown blew me away when
all of a sudden I could shortcut an
enormous amount of the tedious
interactions from working in our scripts
and actually taking the outputs of those
getting it them into word or PDF
documents to distribute
now as many graduate students are
inclined to do I also dabbled in
figuring out how I could use the tools I
was learning in particular are in fun
new ways
so about that time a new tool emerged
called get book and it was really
fascinating to me because the idea was
to take a bunch of markdown documents
Jam them through this processor and out
popped a website that had navigation and
styling and it kind of looked like a
book and so I said hmm that seems kind
of interesting I wonder if I can take
our markdown documents get them to mark
down to put them through getbook and so
I put together some really really scary
looking code but thankfully the rstudio
team was also keeping an eye on such
ideas
and book down entered the scene
this ability to build on a unit of in
our markdown document into more complex
content felt like a taste of
opportunities to come
and so similarly when I started playing
around with what it was going to be like
to build a Blog I found Hugo a static
site generator that you could also make
most of your content with markdown
and so by using that content and
markdown plus a little bit of metadata
and configuration you could generate a
professional looking site
again the rstudio team responded with
blog down
and it was so exciting to me because
there's actually official tools to
support these janky workflows that I was
trying to come up with that integration
between Hugo and markdown was able to
help bring content to life
but it's fascinating as these
experiments were as fascinating as
learning those tools were it was
undeniable that there were some
significant points of friction and
frustration and figuring it out
especially around the tooling boundaries
it was never fun to see a Hugo theme
that just kind of didn't work for how
you wanted to lay it out or something
that worked in bookdown that you
couldn't put into blog down
and so as powerful as these tools were
it was clear that the separation of the
communities that we're trying to meld
together left some gaps to make this
approachable to everyone
but here we are today
it has Minnie and Julie have explained
and hopefully as everyone is getting so
excited about quarto Builds on the
learnings of the past decade
it unifies teams across language
boundaries and procedural differences
and in the same vein gorto can also
unify the way you consider building
those books blogs websites or all sorts
of other complex content
so you can focus on enabling users to
discover
consume and navigate in the ways that
you'd like to help them
and by doing so in a single unified tool
chain it really does give you an
unparalleled ability to control the
processing and ultimately the production
of the content that you're working on
now one thing that some of you may be
thinking is this seems like a lot one
tool that can do so much
how may I even start learning all of the
things that I can do
so today I'm going to do something that
hopefully the presentation Gods will be
with me and I'm going to show you just
how easy it is to get going with quarto
and do some pretty cool stuff and
hopefully also demonstrate about some of
the thoughtfulness that the quarto team
has put into its design
so
switch over
so I can actually see what I'm typing
um
oh man where's my mouse
again
hoping that's going to give it back all
right
I want to mirror
and we're in business
all right
so
let's drop into our studio
now one of the things that you can
always do in our studio is if you want
to go play around with a somewhat recent
version of our studio you can go in
create a new directory and quarto is
front and center
quarter team has wanted to make sure
that Corto is available even if you're
not in using rstudio if you're using vs
code or any other editor and so many to
all the things that you can do in the
IDE you can also do on the command line
in this case we want to get going with a
website
so in this case I can from the terminal
say quarto create project
type equals website
and what this is going to do is start me
off with a scaffold
it has a couple of these qmd files that
you've been hearing about
and it has this quarto.yaml
this is the magic the ability to say I
have the area that I'm going to write my
content and I have a hub where I can
control how I want that content to be
rendered
so if I want to take this content maybe
add a little bit more structure to it so
here is a header
and maybe we'll
add a you know a list
some markdown
some more interesting stuff
and I can render it
and what's going to pop up
is my site
now let's look at this site really
briefly I have a title I have a home and
an about page
you can see my header that I can
actually link to in case I want to get
someone directly there if it's a longer
page
and I even have a table of contents if I
have more elements so I can see how I
would navigate through that page
now you could go build this today in
blog down no problem
but where things start to get exciting
to me in quarto is just how flexible you
can be when you say what if I want to
move things around
so in this case you can see how this is
laid out I have my website I have a
title that I could change I also have a
nav bar so that top strip is a navbar
but if I instead said I want to move my
content so it's on the Left Right which
is actually one of the big things that
would differentiate for like a book it's
quite simple I could just say this is a
sidebar
and I want to take some contents
and if I go back here
and I want to regenerate it
my site now has no navbar and instead my
contents are on the side
you don't have to decide up front is
this a book is this a Blog because
quarto is giving you the ability to put
things in the way you want and you can
combine the ideas that make books great
blogs great or any other different type
of layout and much of that is accessible
directly with a couple lines of code in
this configuration file
foreign
back the nav bar for a little bit and
let's talk about blogs because I think
that's one entry point for a lot of
people where you can start to dabble
with things that you're learning you
know maybe it's stuff at the conferences
maybe it's some of your own personal
learnings that you want to put up to the
world
and so what I want to do is I want to
add some more organization to this
content and so I'm going to make a posts
directory
and in that post directory I'm going to
make a quarto document
my first post
now one of the things that you're going
to see coming up right here is the
visual editor
now this isn't directly relevant to you
know directly enabled only by quarto but
this is something that to me is so
exciting about the blend of what quarto
offers plus what the rstudio IDE can
also bring to the table
so for some people the ability to write
markdown is fine for text but as soon as
you start doing more complex things like
dealing with images it becomes tedious
to remember oh what is that it's
exclamation point bracket or is it
parentheses I can't keep track how do I
get stuff in and suddenly going back to
a Google doc or something feels a lot
more approachable
both quarto and the visual editor you
get that what you see is what you get
interface if you want that now I can
always switch back to the source if I'm
comfortable writing that but the visual
editor has some pretty nice goodies
hidden inside of it
for example if I wanted to clear all of
this out
so let's just take this away real quick
to do
and say I'm here at conf
rstudio
has just rebranded
and you know what I think it would be
great to also add a uh a screenshot so
I'm going to save this into my posts I'm
going to say my conference
experience
and let's go over to the court or the
the new posit website
and for fun and games I'm gonna whoops
that went pretty fast I'm gonna grab a
little screenshot maybe boom I grabbed
that screenshot I'm going to copy it to
my clipboard
now before the visual editor I'd have to
save this out I'd have to put it in a
directory I'd have to move that around
I much prefer just pasting it
and the visual editor has now taken that
and stuck it in an image's directory for
me
these quality of life improvements are
all throughout the Corto ecosystem
to Showcase another one real quick if I
look here and I wonder you know oh what
was it was it sidebar was it side
something I can start typing and with
some tab completion it's going to tell
me what my options are
now notice this isn't a long list of
every possible option it's just the
options relevant for that level of
indentation
in this case I could say true or false
or if I indent again
and then ask and say tell me what things
I could do with the sidebar you see this
come up right here and I can say oh yeah
I could put some contents in
the things that could frustrate you to
make you you feel like you needed to
pull your hair out
IDE and Corto and the tooling built
around it is trying to help you not have
to deal with that and be able to focus
on your content
and so I have this first uh kind of
conference experience uh a page here and
I I'm what I'm going to do is I'm also
going to go kind of Steal just for the
sake of time another kind of post
starter that I grabbed right off of the
quarto website so we can also stick this
in the posts page
um
all right
so what we have here
is I've added another
more complex quarter document that has a
bunch more stuff going on to it and the
the majority of the intent of this
doesn't matter so much this is on the
quarto website so you can explore about
it but the point is I'm starting to
build up multiple blog posts and so how
are you going to display those for your
user if we think about what a Blog might
have you might have something that's
sorted by date it shows an author maybe
an image preview it gives that stuff to
you so you can see what's going on
and so uh instead of making it look like
it's magical and I can remember how to
do this off the top of my head this is a
great opportunity to go over to the
court of site to say if this was the
first time I was considering trying to
build a Blog and I wanted to go look at
it I can go and look through the search
and quarto is going to give you a whole
bunch of information on that site about
what to do for blogging
and so in this case I can scroll down a
little bit and they say hey if you are
dealing with a Blog you can grab this
and what we can see here is the idea of
some configuration that allows us to say
you're going to want to display some
listings you have some content that's
going to be a bunch of different posts
you know qmd documents or otherwise and
you're probably going to want to do
something with this
so let's just steal this right from the
site
I'm going to make a new document
and
we're just going to come in
we're going to clear it all out and I'm
just going to paste this in
so call this the blog
save it
and in the top we'll call this the blog
should I get in the right spot all right
so now I have this blog qmd file and I
just have to say where I want it to be
in this case I'd be completely fine with
it being right next to that home and
that about so I'll say text is blog
and href is
blog Dot qmd
now notice the contents are the contents
is this posts folder if I had a
different folder name I'd give it a
different thing
so now let's go check at what this whole
site is going to look like
so everything got rendered I can go to
my about page I can go to my blog and
you can see here that I have these pages
that I can click in and I already have a
pretty great looking thing right out of
the box that shows all sorts of
information about it you can see the
author the publication date and a whole
bunch of images
now content is great looking at it on
your laptop but realistically the true
excitement is when you can actually get
this out to the world
and so the quarto team has also wanted
to make sure they could make this as
easy as possible for everyone
and so I'm going to come in here I did
notice as I was copying things around I
blew away that old posit image so let me
go clean that that uh kind of broken
link up real quick I saw the air flash
around so if I go into my images post
uh that copy paste of the the starter
killed it off so I want to save that
real quick
so here I am I want to get this to the
world so let's go back to the quarto
command line
in this case I can say
quarto publish and there are a number of
different endpoints if you use rstudio
connect that is of course one of them
there's netlify if you've ever heard
that but one other thing that I'm so
excited to show is quarto pubs
and in this case I can say I would
absolutely like to publish I have a site
that by default is going to be the
folder name but I can give it any name I
want
and up it goes
it's uploading all of the elements to
the site
deploying it
in just a moment
we now have a live site available to the
world
now I know I'm running a little bit
short on time and I have a couple more
things that I want to show
and to me the thing if I look at this
blog and I look at this
fun photography filled site with a bunch
of complex layout that is great to kind
of inspect and analyze this is all well
and good but wouldn't it be nice if we
could add some more interactivity
and so one of the things that kind of
made me a little nervous when looking at
quarto you know one tool chain to rule
them all is what if you want to do
something that's not in the tool chain
and so what the quarto team has done is
they've built up this concept of quarto
extensions
we have a couple extensions already out
there and so in this case one of the
extensions is called the light box
extension and so this allows you to add
some styling to images and so you can
see right here there are some great
installation instructions so let's just
see what happens if we run this
I'm going to say absolutely I do trust
the authors my extent I've now installed
an extension right from GitHub into my
site
and then I can go and I can go to this
pictures page and in the configuration
we can see you need to add this extra
little bit of syntax on filters and
lightbox
so let's take a look at what this looks
like now
so if I go to this fun photography now I
have what to me comes out as a much more
professional photography looking website
I can pop things out
you can scroll across them with the
magic of pulling in an extension and
extensions can do this and so much more
if you want to think about themes for
your company layouts for documents or
all sorts of other Advanced
functionality there's a whole bunch of
delight that these extensions are
bringing to the table
you might have heard of vetiver
one of the cool things about vetiver is
it is multilingual but that meant
bringing multilingual code Snippets
throughout the entire site
but if you want to go and you're
interested in Python I don't want to
have to click through python across
every single tab on the site
One Core to extension made now all of my
tabs are synced across the language that
I pick every single time I come back to
this
so the quarto extension ecosystem is
going to allow the community and the
quarter to developers to really take
Corto and expand to do so much more
beyond what it can even do out of the
box
so there's so so much that we haven't
had time to talk to about today with
quarto so I want to close with one
suggestion
there's a gallery in quarto that covers
a whole bunch of stuff that you can do
with it
go there for some inspiration you know
of course things like the quarto website
is there but there are people that are
generating some really awesome hybrid uh
hybrid sites that can do so much
one of the you know my favorites that
I've seen is like this mlr3 book this is
what a book looks like with quarter that
you can make and there are so many
little good bits like the fact that you
can actually embed the code that
generated the site right there to pop
out if you like things like light themes
or dark themes or otherwise there is so
much to discover there so take a look
read around and most importantly go out
and play with quarto you can get going
so fast
and you can have so much fun while
you're at it
and while you're along that please don't
hesitate to reach out to the Porto team
and so with that I'll just kind of leave
this up there
but I really hope you all go out and
build thank you
[Applause]
[Music]